that's exactly how it works is people
think oh if i practice stoicism i'll
become that person who is
calm mind and able to just operate and
doesn't have these sort of like
massive swings and it's like no it's the
other way around
when once you learn to tame the mind
once you learn to master the mind
you'll naturally become a stoic person
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what i want to i put my all in it like
no days off on the road let's travel
never looking back
what up all right what's going on um
i'm in nashville wait it's uh
is it eight or seven where you are seven
oh it's seven wow it's really so i woke
up a little bit late and i texted you
and i go you just want to record
something right now and he said yeah i'm
thankful you said yes
yeah let's give it a shot you're at a
podcasting conference which sounds
like not a ton of fun is it a ton of fun
though
so it's educational and i'm happy and
i'm learning
but it's just like nerdy stuff and uh
you know there's not like i don't want
to i can't absorb it for that long but
i'm happy that i i would love
yeah it's worth it it's cool
people uh people like know us and that's
crazy like it's crazy just to walk
around
it's it's at a hotel and like so
everyone's staying and it's kind of
funny to be walking around and
just people come up to you and say that
they like listen so that's kind of neat
because it's all podcast nerds
yeah okay i like that uh you learn
anything cool any hacks any any growth
hacks for us or what
i think youtube is just the way to go so
and that's what we'll be doing with this
show is
going hard podcasting is for nerds we're
going to youtube
no i mean well um that's the way to go
some of these people spend so for the
listeners
shawn and i spit it's not our money
anymore but when we were doing this like
we were like so
cheap and i actually think too cheap
about starting this podcast i mean i
think it was right how we did it with
like
really uh bad at first and then it got a
little bit better and a little bit
better
but people spend so much money on
recording their stuff
and i actually don't think that's
important but when you have something
like we have which is like you kind of
hit this lick
it's important to invest and i think
we've under invested which is crazy
yeah maybe i don't know i was renting a
studio the first
10 10 20 episodes 100 an hour so that
was a that was like a professional setup
i went i thought i was going
i thought i was over investing at that
time because i had zero listeners when i
recorded those
yeah no but that's my point is that uh
my perspective has changed when i'm
seeing like some of the budgets that
people have
um but for this episode i like i called
you because i saw like
three amazing things that i wanted to
bring up to you and you have one two
three four five
uh interesting things and i just wanted
to talk to you about them
all right let's do them what do you
where you want to start give me give me
your first one okay the first one that i
we didn't get to last time but i wanted
to fill you in about it uh
and it's uh about the oh i'm just
writing notes it's about the elevator
business
so i told you a little bit about this so
i like
there's this was one of these moments
and i've had them with you a ton
where you explained something and you're
like i didn't even know that this was a
problem i didn't even know this was an
industry
but now i'm totally bought in and i
think it's amazing
and this particular comp and well in
this particular company
i'm not sure i don't it's not because i
think that they're bad i just don't know
them well enough to actually believe
that they're gonna win
but like it was pretty amazing so let me
set the stage so
i believe there's something like i might
be off by
a little bit but i believe there's
something like two million elevators in
america
and only four companies basically
control the whole elevator business have
have you ever
been on an elevator and looked at your
feet where the doors opened and seen the
names
yeah you there's this little like plaque
there but i don't remember any of their
names i don't i don't
i i can't recall i once threw my key in
the crack and had to call one of the
companies to be like hey
how do how do i get under your elevator
wow so it's
otis you probably recognize that's the
big one yeah yeah
otis schindler cone and uh mishibi
is that uh yeah miss mushibi
mitsubishi um are the big ones i know of
otis because i've already
i've looked into them a bunch they're
not technically these four
aren't technically a monopoly because
there's more than one but basically they
control
just about everything and what that
means is
um when you buy an elevator i'm not
actually sure how how much an elevator
costs
but something like like target might
have
six or seven thousand elevators and when
you buy an elevator from them
it's a like 10-year or 20-year contract
it's a really long contract and it's
almost like buying a car so when you buy
a car
you get a 50 000 mile warranty and
except imagine buying 5 000 cars
and it's incredibly challenging to know
when each car needs to be serviced what
type of service the
the car company is actually going to pay
for and what they're not going to pay
for
what falls under it is kind of a pain in
the butt
and so what happens is oftentimes a
company like target they employ
a whole team to manage their elevators
and escalators and they don't know like
you know what they have to do and
instead of fighting with otis and
deciding they just go ah [__] it we're
just gonna call service people and we're
gonna
we're gonna get figure out on our own
and there's two new companies one is
called audit mate that's who i talk to
but there's one in
britain called we maintain that's raised
40 million dollars
and basically what they do is they
manage your elevator and
escalator um like it's like fleet
management you know what i mean
right they determine what and i thought
that this was so fascinating and very
interesting and when i heard about this
company
uh i was like well i don't necessarily
want i'm not sure if i ever want to like
invest in anything like this but i would
love to own it and so the way it works
is they charge
50 to 60 a month per elevator
and the name of the game is you just go
out and find all the elevators and you
say look
we're gonna be your your agent which
means we sign on to speak on your behalf
and we're gonna negotiate with otis and
we're gonna make sure that your shit's
maintained
it doesn't break down and we're gonna
handle all of it and i thought that that
was amazing
and it's one of these business models
where it's kind of like the way that
they charge you right now
or a lot of these companies charge is a
subscription fee which is fine
but this is one of those business models
that we've talked about like uh turbo
tax where they take a percentage of all
savings so this is like the easiest [__]
ever to sell
right and so anyway they're basically
saying hey you have no no risk no loss
because we're gonna save you money
you know you sign up to pay you sign up
with us we're gonna save you money and
we'll take
we'll take out of it in the same way
that um you know like main street does
this with
tax savings basically for you they'll be
like all right uh
we'll take a percentage of whatever we
save you it's like oh okay sounds like i
have no downside
and even if that percentage is large
it's like found money so they feel good
about it
i thought and i thought this was cool
i've never have you ever even heard of
anything like this
no dude so you so i'm just looking at
some of your notes otis
12.5 billion in revenue schindler 11.6
billion cone
basically the same 10 billion in revenue
uh
huge those are huge revenues for for
these companies now i don't know how
profitable the elevator business is but
well they're like family owned otis is
like a family-owned business i'm almost
positive otis has been around
since the 1800s i mean these are like
huge huge
family-owned businesses so they
definitely are i believe they they have
to be
profitable um here otis oh otis says 12
but the otis is publicly traded
so what do you think their uh market cap
is uh for 12 billion in revenue
okay i'm gonna guess they are a
22 billion dollar company might be less
i think it could be less
you think less i think less oh it's
about 40.
40. okay so i was 22 i was off uh i was
so okay
pretty crazy right like who would have
thought and so this is just software
that lets you negotiate twitter twitter
is like 50
75 or something like that so is it
really what
is the elevator company yeah twitter had
been hovering below that and then now it
says 5560 or something like that because
the stock went up recently but
um basically otis the elevator company
is worth almost as much as twitter
which is insane and not only that i
believe let's see it's been around since
1853.
yeah amazing so it's the funny thing is
this is named after like a guy's first
name it sounds like
not even it's like it's just it was it
was the the company was uh
invented in yonkers new york in 1853
and they've been around since then
[__] elevators and so this fascinates
me when i like learned about this
because you know i like old [__]
when i think about you and i and a bunch
of friends were talking what is yonkers
is jonker's a place you never see
yonkers is somebody born in yonkers
because that's amazing i want to say i'm
from yonkers melon
yeah it's in uh it's in the i believe
it's in the bronx in new york it's like
a it's like
i don't know it's in new york yeah i'm
from yonkers in the bronx all right
well uh so so this company but you're
what you're saying is that this company
is a sas company on top of those
right yeah it's a sas company that lives
on top of it and here's why this
fascinates me
i love old [__] things that last a long
time and
we were talking about like the creator
economy sub stack i don't remember what
we were talking about
something like involving like uh one of
these newsletter
like one-off creators and it's like yeah
i think you can make a lot of money but
can you do that for 20 or 30 years it's
really really challenging i think right
basically sam's type on companies did
you start in the 1800s
in some way did you um did you have a
physical product
that you could feel that you could touch
and feel did where you started in the
midwest
or some some part of america you know
are you named after a family like
rockefeller or schindler or otis
or or something like that uh let's see
what else what else is it you know are
you absurdly profitable
uh what those are your those are your
type essentially
yeah look i think it's cool that's
something that to build something that
can last a really long time yeah that
interests me
because that that that like you you
optimized for excitement i think
or uh interest i optimize for what's the
least amount of work i can do in order
to like
have freedom and you're bothering
yourself more like durability
and and i feel like durability is like
number one it's like yeah you just
if you have this you win and i'm like if
you have this you might win for an hour
and then you might lose the next hour
like i'm cool with that so both work
but they're both work they're just
different what um what what do you what
do you have what do you what are you
doing let me give you one
all right so uh what i want to do let's
do
let's do the zoo um okay let's do this
unbundling etsy one
so i'm really interested in the second
tier or like what i'll call b-class
uh marketplaces i don't mean that as an
insult i mean it more like if you're in
real estate you're like oh do i buy an a
you know a class property which is like
it's a modern building
fully leased uh blah blah or do you go
for like an older thing that has
upside right do you go for something
that has some hair on the deal that you
might be able to do
and so you go you know this is not new
york right
like that marketplace might be amazon um
etsy or
poshmark are these like second-tier
marketplaces but i see a lot of
opportunity in them
we talked about i think we talked about
this about building
sas tools for sellers uh on those market
places so
you you you brought that up and i and i
thought that was a pretty revolutionary
thing that that was a big idea
and so these exist but they're not great
and there's not a lot of competition and
so like
i think we talked about jungle scout
which sold for some large amount of
money that you knew
um jungle scout is a tool for sellers on
amazon
and i was thinking okay who's building
stuff like this on these second-tier
marketplaces like etsy or poshmark
uh so that was the first idea then i
started thinking okay wait that
can are you gonna elaborate on that
because that's pretty amazing well i
think
didn't we talk about it maybe we talked
about i thought we talked about it no if
not no
that's not i think i don't know if you
phrased it that way i think the your
the story telling here that you just
said is actually wonderful
so i think that's actually brilliant we
had so at hustle con we had poshmark
thread up and one more of these
companies
speak and yeah i think they were some of
the biggest murkari
mercari's a big one yeah they're huge
secondhand sales
the real real you know there's all these
like other marketplaces basically
there's all these
other other places so ben's wife uh
tiffany
she is a poshmark like super seller or
something like that
and so she like she sold so much that
like when they ipo they invited her and
like whatever the top
other thousand sellers be like do you
want to buy the ipo you can buy
the reserve price basically we're
reserving some shares for you because
you've helped build this thing
for which company for poshmark and like
airbnb did the same i think i think for
they they offered super host ability to
buy some share some some small amount of
shares
and so um an airbnb by the way another
another marketplace where could you
build a jungle scout type of tool on top
of it
there is that i'm a subscriber to it's
called air dna
it's amazing and what does that do it
tells you like what to price it at or
yeah so it's called air dna and
when i was so i rent out my house when
i'm not there and
i buy property to rent out and i use it
as a research tool
and i guess it just crawls airbnb and it
determines what the average occupancy
rate is what you should charge what the
earning potential is
it's just it's tons of signals for
buying properties to
make into an airbnb and there might be
other things like
reporting you know uh tax you know some
tax savings you can get or whatever if
you
if you're an airbnb host it plugs into
your airbnb and it generates your your
report
um so anyways i was thinking okay you
could build a jungle scout type of tool
and for those who don't know what jungle
scout is basically you go on
amazon if you have jungle scout
installed it's a chrome extension
and basically when you are looking for
products
you can just click jungle scout and
it'll tell you hey here's how much
search volume this has how much monthly
revenue this product makes
it's an estimate but it's pretty good uh
here's how fast it's growing and here's
how strong the competition is
and so what you want to find is
something that there's a lot of search
uh
and low competition and if you find some
if you find a combination like that
you're like oh nobody's searching for
you know wooden spoons that are like
wooden oversized spoons
uh you don't want to build that because
nobody's searching for it but if you
have like
you know wooden oversized baby spoons
it's high search low low competition you
could go
go to china get that product made and
become like the top result on amazon
which is basically free traffic for you
so that's the idea so i think you could
do that for poshmark i think you could
do that for etsy
one thing that i was thinking about for
etsy is i think you could spin off a
whole new marketplace just
unbundling etsy etsy is now big enough
it's a public company been around for a
decade plus
and um has all these different
categories right so it's like
you can go and you can go to home you
can go to you know custom gifts you can
go to all these different
categories on etsy and you can ask
yourself huh
could i make a marketplace of or or a
service that just does
this one thing better than etsy's doing
market it as that
and actually like unbundle a piece of
etsy in the same way that people have
had a lot of success unbundling reddit
unbundling craigslist if you haven't
seen this google google unbundling
craigslist and look at the diagram it's
like
it takes every part of craigslist and
then it just shows how
oh look this housing part of craigslist
became airbnb and this became
etsy and this became this other thing
and so the same thing i think can be
done here so here's
that's the that's the core idea is
unbuttle one of the verticals of etsy
what i would do i was looking at the
categories
i would do custom gifs so custom gifs is
one of the top categories on etsy
and people go there because they want to
send a thoughtful kind of like
what looks like a homemade handmade gift
to somebody
or they're getting it made for like
their wedding and they want all their
wedding coasters to have their names on
them or their bachelor party and they
want everybody to have matching shirts
that say the bat the the bachelorette's
name on it or whatever
um and so i think custom gifs could be
spun out into a marketplace that's like
fiverr
where it's basically just uh here's a
bunch of custom gifs
push a button and you get these for you
know 10 bucks or some some flat rate
basically
so i think you could do a fiverr or or
even like a cameo style thing for custom
gifts
and that's the that's the category i
would go after but i think generally
i think you could study their
marketplace and find it find a we'll
find one that works because you can also
see the shop
sales you can go into any shop on etsy
and you can see how many sales it's at
which is like you can do that an
entrepreneur
is now right yeah this is part of etsy
it's like
you know here this shop has had six
thousand orders and you can look at the
price
price of the store be like oh you know
average thanks 35 dollars that'd be like
6 000 times 35 that's how much revenue
this stop
the shop has made in two years those are
both two big ideas
um so you're talking about building like
the the
the software that analyzes the sales and
then the um
the marketplace that sells the stuff
both actually pretty amazing
i go to etsy sometimes and i do so if
you scroll all the way to the bottom
you'll see how many sales they have
ebay does it too um but not as good but
that's actually a great idea i
and and by the way i looked up air dna
so the thing about these software
companies uh
you're you're talking about two
different things we'll call it one
software one marketplace the software
companies
so if i told you or if you told me about
jungle scout a few years ago i would say
like oh that's a nice little
that's a nice little hacker business
yeah yeah well
it it probably does like 80 or i mean
if it's worth a billion i wouldn't be
surprised but it's definitely worth nine
figures i know that for a fact
because it sold part of their company so
i told you just about air dna
i thought that was just a small thing
how big do you think air dna is
by the way jungle scout raised over 110
million dollars which is
that gives you a sense of how big it is
if it was yeah i think it was
some of it was private equity so i don't
know how big the valuation was but it's
definitely huge
right okay air dna i don't even know
what it does i've never been to a
website so i'm just gonna take i'm just
gonna say a random number
out of the air i'm gonna say 35 million
what is there worth well so the air dna
so they charge i think i pay a hundred
dollars a month for it
in 2018 they did 4.9 million in revenue
in 2019 they did 8.4 million dollars in
revenue
they said they were going 100 so you
could probably assume that i would i
would actually bet that in 2020 they
probably did 16 and then 21 i i wouldn't
be surprised
because uh there's a lot going on with
investing in airbnbs i wouldn't be
surprised
if they're in the 30 million recurring
revenue annual recurring revenue range
and they raised eight million dollars in
order to uh
build up they bootstrapped to nine
million in revenue and then raised eight
million dollars
so these are like these things that you
would think are small insignificant
stuff
that could actually be quite big so
that's a that's a 50 to 100 million
dollar
your value business uh at that roughly
those numbers you just told me
yeah it's a huge thing and who would
have thought i never would have thought
that if you just told me you're gonna
build this thing
that analyzes airbnb i'd be like no i
would have been like side hustles are
cool yeah yeah you should be able to
bring in the 45k a month
you know with your little airbnb dna
tracker whatever the hell you're talking
about
and and i would say i i i would have if
you had to guess what's bigger
etsy sellers or airbnb i would think
there'd be more etsy sellers than airbnb
hosts
well the thing with etsy sellers is that
um
so airbnb is very much it's a lot more
set it and forget it and there's less
levers to pull
and there's less like um there's less
like categories and things like that
whereas like etsy has like multiple
different categories each one has its
own little nuances
uh and then there's like such a wide
variety of sellers where
yes there's many people have houses but
it's all they're all doing the same
they're offering the same service etsy's
offering like a million different
services to people
um and so i think that's why it has
probably a little more opportunity
what would you do why did you call it
cameo
well i was just thinking custom gifts if
custom gifts is this big of a market
i would just start with that i'd say
custom gifts i wouldn't maybe the
end product wouldn't be a physical gift
like etsy maybe it would be
something like a cameo where it's a
video or just making a jingle for
somebody
or it could be with celebrities or
non-celebrities but basically some way
to send a custom gift to somebody
if that's such a big uh such a big
part of etsy maybe you could rank for it
in search or run google
ads and hijack some of that traffic of
people looking for
custom you know handmade whatever custom
name blah blah blah and be like yeah we
do that
we'll put your name on a shirt yeah it's
not as nice as etsy it's
you know we just took the generic etsy
look and we just mass produce it
basically
um that that that'd be one way i'm on
board with that
um you want to move on to another one
yeah yeah all right
so i'm gonna weave two one of mine in
one of yours i
i'm a big ufc fan so are you so dc
daniel cormier he is uh he's retired now
but he's a big fighter
and he he posted this thing and i'd seen
ads for it but he posted that he's now
gonna endorse this thing called fit to
warrior and i went and looked at it so
fit to warrior it's incredibly
interesting and so what they do
is you spend twenty two hundred dollars
and in
six months they take you is it six
months maybe three months i think six
months
they take you from being a complete noob
so you're just a guy off the street
to warrior oh sorry i spelled it yeah
it's whip my bad
that fit to warrior wouldn't make sense
it's called wimp to warrior
uh wimp two warrior they take just you
off the street
you give them twenty two hundred dollars
and i think you get like a hundred
classes or fifty classes what did i
write fif so
uh so it's a 20 week program how many
months is 20 weeks
five so five months in okay so you have
five months
and what they do is you sign up and you
have a fight
you have a fight scheduled five months
from the day you sign up
and it's like and it's like cohort based
you pay like twenty five hundred dollars
or something like that
of course yeah yeah it's a cohort based
thing and they say
in the next five months we're gonna take
a guy off the street
and you're gonna have an mma fight now
it doesn't take a rocket scientist to
understand that the goal of this
is not necessarily to get you fit or to
like get in a fight
the goal of this is to have like a
pivotal change in your life
to be more confident to say like look
i've
i've said i'm gonna lose weight forever
now i like i have a fight in five months
if i don't get my act together like i'm
really it's not a good it's not going to
be good
so this is like a pivotal life-changing
thing and i love this business they just
raised 8 million
from a bunch of pe people it was
launched in australia and basically what
they're doing is they came up with this
name went to warrior they come up with
this program
and they work with loads of different
mma and i guess boxing gyms
and they license out their program and
now they are paying conor mcgregor's
coach john cavanaugh's on board
dc all these coaches to like promote it
and they give them
some type of fee i thought this was
amazing and i think this is amazing
for a couple reasons one it's a business
that i actually think this would change
your life
if i told you you had to if i told you
you had a fight in five months would
that be the one thing that finally like
said like
i gotta take this am i wrong that you
think
basically this should be mandatory part
of the education system
well so look here's the thing everybody
to do this here's what here's
here's why this has always fascinated me
so women have this because they have
like a biological like
you are now officially a woman but men
we've lost like a rite of passage we've
never had this like
all right now i'm officially a man like
i guess if you're jewish and you have a
bar mitzvah maybe that's like the
like the crossing of the cast of like
all right you are no longer a boy now
you are a man
and like we had this like i i love uh
the sparks
the spartans because they do this thing
where they like you'd go they'd say all
right you're 14 or whatever now you got
to go out in the wild for five days and
you gotta survive
and just come back when you're done men
american
we don't really have this like this this
modern day
yeah yeah and so i love these type of
transformational like
all right it is official you have
there's a start beginning and then like
an end type of thing
so i love that and you up here you want
to talk about mental fitness
i've also done like yoga or not yoga um
meditation i love head space i love calm
i i try to i do buy into mental fitness
stuff but it's a little bit tough
because
it's not like intense and so i love
these intense programs
and i think that they can be great
businesses and incredibly fun and
fulfilling to run
yeah so i think there's a couple things
first i i had seen this i thought
uh mcgregor's coach john cavanaugh i
thought he invented this
because he was the first one always
talking about oh we're doing wimp to
warrior it's so good we have 200 people
doing it this season
and he just kept doing it and it was
like they take average joes you come in
and you basically say
cool i'm gonna turn into a fighter i'm
gonna train like a fighter
for x amount of weeks and then i it
ended
kind of the graduation the culmination
the rite of passage at the end
is you do the likes the the amateur
exhibition fight or whatever with
somebody else from the program i think
so it's not
like you're not in a ton of danger
i think it's really cool i didn't
realize that there was like a business
underneath this
and so just to do the math so basically
what they're doing is
they're licensing this out to gyms and
they're saying hey this is a great
um customer recruitment like mechanism
right so
you you run a wimp to warrior program
we'll give you the branding we'll give
you the business in a box kit
and what you get and we'll send you the
customers
and we'll send you customers because we
have star athletes and coaches
promoting this because it's a feel-good
thing for them too
and and so we'll send you a bunch of
interest people they'll find a wimp to
warrior program near them and you be my
operator
so it's asset light you do all the work
we will just do the marketing and create
the brand on top of this
i think this is actually really really
smart i would invest in this company
um even though it seems like so crazy
fringe
uh i i i there's a there's a very nice
model
um it's better than tough mudder better
than spartan race better than all those
because they take on a ton of
operational overhead they're a traveling
circus
and so i i like this model a lot better
so okay i think whimp to warrior's cool
i think that your rite of passages write
a passage thing is interesting and
especially we talked early on about boy
scouts and like the downfall of the boy
scouts program
and what you would do if you were gonna
buy it or reinvent it or make a new boy
scouts
and i think we were onto something with
this and we should keep
looking for the opportunities that are
here um
i'm i'll tie this into the mental
fitness thing we
we did a segment on simone biles in a
podcast
two two episodes ago one episode ago
yeah and we ended up cutting it so it's
only
it's it's in the lost archive lost files
along with me and sam sparring footage
from when i went to his house in
austin and the reason we cut it is
because i had a strong take i was pretty
like
so but we didn't i didn't have i didn't
have all the details of the story i
didn't realize that there i thought this
was
when she said i had like a mental
breakdown i was like oh that's
like crazy like that's nuts but then
yeah
yeah and then there's like these like
the twisties things i'm like all right
well that's like
that that's like an injury that's like
your leg's broken type of thing
so my opinion changed and i was like ah
i didn't actually have all the facts
when i was
when i was kind of explaining my opinion
yeah
uh yeah that's that's true and so we we
basically were like
we sent it to sam's wife and we were
like hey what do you think too much
it was like yeah a little too much
that's how we cut it
but i i thought there was one part of it
that was interesting right like so
yeah nobody really cares about sean and
sam's opinion on simon biles
even though kind of that's whatever it
can be interesting the more crazy your
reaction the more interesting it gets
i thought the more interest i thought
the real part in it was
there's going to be a trend i'm calling
it now over the next
five to seven years people are going to
start to really give a [__] about mental
fitness and it's a very different thing
than mental health
just like for your physical body you
have health like
do you have a disease are you ill like
no i i'm not i'm not sick
but you can be not sick but you can be
not fit at the same time
and um right so so you could be healthy
but not fit
and in the same way you could have
mental health meaning you don't
uh you're not suffering from you know
depression
uh severe anxiety bipolar anything like
that
but you can also not be mentally fit and
you know so what's a fit person right
sam's a really fit person
uh you're really physically fit if you
work out with sam you go for a run with
sam you'll be like god damn this guy can
run he's
you know he can go long distances he's
he's fit and so similarly there's mental
fitness which is basically
just like in physical fitness it's about
overcoming some adversity
so a mentally fit person is somebody who
can overcome a high degree of and
variety
of of adversity and intensity of diverse
of adversity and so um you know [__] not
going your way
getting in sticky situations being out
of your comfort zone
these are all areas where mental fitness
matters
relationships uh different different
challenges that come your way
is where mental fitness matters and i
think right now this is something that
is very poorly
understood it's rarely talked about it's
almost never taught
but i would say mental fitness is in my
opinion
the most important skill one can have
right the most
important thing is the little voice in
your head
that's talking all day non-stop this
chatter box we have in our head
and what is it telling yourself is it
telling yourself that you suck that you
can't do it
is it telling yourself that you should
give up this is too hard is it telling
yourself that
uh you know don't do it things might go
wrong or is it saying the opposite is it
saying uh you know what you could figure
this out hey
um even if it doesn't work out no
problem you know you'll still
everything will still be okay hey even
though this this person just cut you off
on the road
look at look around the sky is blue the
air is crisp
your family is happy and healthy you
have a lot to be grateful for right like
the voice
in your head dictates the quality of
your life and the voice in your head
is your mental fitness it is it is the
the manifestation of your mental fitness
and so i think we're going to be seeing
a lot around this i think we're going to
be seeing
growth in services content thought
leaders
whatever around mental fitness what do
you think am i
overblowing this or is that are you a
believer
i'm a believer i think that what you're
doing with this title mental fitness is
i think you're just
re-branding something that's been around
for a long time you know this is like a
tony robbins book
so i i i totally buy into what you're
saying and i and i 100 agree with it
i think there's a few opportunities here
the first
is so i'm reading this amazing book
called human nature i've been reading it
for a long time
for like six months and it's it's very
dense but i've i'll read it and read it
over and over
and over again and i take notes and i'm
trying to like master it because to me
it's like a handbook on how to like
handle
my emotions and how to handle other
people now
what i would do with this is what i
would want to do is almost have like a
wimp to warrior type of program
where i can spend a fair bit of money
and have a very intense program and i
think that a mental fitness type thing
i think that's a lifetime of learning
and a lot that's like a lifetime journey
but i do think that there is like
transformational moments and series of
your life that could actually level you
up significantly
and i think that there's an opportunity
to build something like that in this
weird kind of [__] up way
i've always been a little bit jealous of
people who went to the military or at
least
people who um went to military school
because like there's this like classic
like i was undisciplined
i was fat i was unhealthy i wouldn't
wake up early
now i make my bed i know how to like
show respect to
each other to people i have
self-confidence i know i
have a a a new level of discipline and
i'm like oh my god
i know what i'm made of i went through
hell week and i made it
so i i have been to my breaking point
beyond my breaking point
where there was just no way and and i
did it
and you know they don't brag about it
but you could tell there's a certain
level of confidence that people have
by discovering your bottom right what is
your actual rock bottom
not not not in terms of your money but
in terms of like
your mental your mental game where you
break you break physically yeah
sure but when you break mentally it's
over and uh
and so they've been there because you
know that's what the military does they
challenge you in that way
and i've always been jealous of that i'm
like man i wish that like i make a i
like i say in a joke away but i'm not
actually joking when i'm with my wife
i'm like
i i wish i would have went to military
school because like there's some like
discipline
stuff that i don't have that i wish i
would i would have had and it's almost
like
i've searched for like what type of
program's going to go to where it's like
uh
it's like basically like the like the
the the soft version of that it's like a
like a fat camp
version of that where i can just like
spend money and they just like insult me
for a week
but uh anyway i think that's like i
think there's something there with that
and i also think that there's something
there with
mastering some of these books and some
of these things um
and doing this mental fitness type of
type of stuff and so i'm on board with
this i actually think this is quite
amazing
yeah and i think the the word is amazing
and this concept this concept of
look you're healthy you're not like
ruined but
you're not fit i think that's amazing i
love um you know who could like crush us
if they wanted to but i don't think they
they do have you bit paid attention to
what ryan holiday has done with his
stoic
brand no
like i'm from before but i don't know
anything specific
i've seen his books but tell me what's
interesting
so ryan holiday is an author his first
book was called
how to get famous or what was it called
how to
it's like news jacking or whatever yeah
i forget what it was called
the obstacle is the way ego is the enemy
or something like that he's got a buddy
yeah so he's got obstacles wait you go
and
this whole idea is based on stoicism
which is this uh
what are they greek i don't know marcus
aurelius these philosophies of basically
like
you're gonna face hardship in your life
and it's not about avoiding them but
it's about embracing them and finding
meaning
in them and it's great and these and
it's probably predominantly male
young males who listen to his stuff i'm
one of them and he's built this brand
called the daily stoic so i believe it's
called dailystoic.com
and he sells 25 stoicism coins
which i own one he sells um like a 19
email course where every 14 days he
teaches you like a new stoicism
like thing on how to read more like and
it's
it's pretty amazing and like if i don't
think he would ever want to do this
because
he he seems like he's got a good life
and he doesn't want to work much harder
but i i i would imagine that if ryan
holliday had like a stowaway
stoiism boot camp for like a month and
he charged like 10 grand
and like it was around this mental
fitness idea i think loads of loads of
people including me would
would pay to go yeah by the way i heard
something that i thought was great they
go
a lot of people get it backwards i
forgot who said this uh they were
talking about stoicism
and i was like yeah you know stoicism
you know i get it you're supposed to be
stoic and then that that brings you sort
of this calm and this peace and this
like sort of like really stable mental
mental game
and uh he goes no it's the other way
around
when you calm the mind you become stoic
you don't become stoic to calm the mind
and uh i thought oh that's so true which
is that
you um that's exactly how it works
is people think oh if i practice
stoicism i'll become that person who is
calm mind and able to just operate and
doesn't have these sort of like
massive swings and it's like no it's the
other way around
when once you learn to tame the mind
once you learn to master the mind
you'll naturally become a stoic person
um you have to get that get the order
back get the order right
and uh so that was like a big
breakthrough for me because i know i
know a lot of people
that have tried to get into stoicis they
have this
anxiety they have this like sort of
mental like
lack of clarity and calmness they get
into stoicism thinking it's the answer
and they get sort of disillusioned very
quickly they're like oh yeah it wasn't
for me
and it's like well that's true because
stoicism is almost a state you get to
after you learn how to calm the mind
it's not the method you use
you know so i've read a lot of stoicism
books and i like it from just a history
perspective and i like it from a
practical life philosophy perspective i
think it's one of the very few like
philosophical things that you could
apply to your daily life you know whose
book
changed my it kind of changed my life on
it and it was shocking it was naval
that naval almanac what's it called
right the navalminec
it's so good it's so good so the first
half
is all about making money and the second
half is all about being happy
and the first half is like that's just
normal whatever who cares
the second half i felt was was pretty
game changing and he talks a lot about
stoicism and a lot about mental fitness
and i and he was basically like
uh the the the summary is basically
happiness is a choice that i made
and here's some of the strategies that i
use and it's very sto
it is stoicism and i thought it was very
useful all right let's uh let's jump to
a different topic uh real quick
can i wait let me quick tell you really
quick about
one of the greatest hacks that i've seen
so a financial hack
so when starting a company so the first
one that i always tell people and this
is something that's new to me that a lot
of people or was new to me a lot of
people don't know about it's called qsbs
so it's probably the greatest american
uh tax adv basically when you sell your
company if you have qsbs which basically
is like
the it basically means qualified small
business tax so if you sell a business
and you've owned the business stock for
five years
and it's a c corp if you sell your
company
the first 10 million dollars in sales
are
in uh and profit that you make for your
company you don't pay taxes on so it's
amazing
but i think i found something that's
even better um
moving to canada so i talked to this
company the other day
and they they were building this like
amazing thing and i was like huh
how many people work there you're like a
really new company and they're like well
we have about 18 people who work here
and we only spend about a million
dollars a year uh in total cost
and that's kind of cool so basically
when you're starting a company i started
my company in san francisco if you're
starting your company
i i would imagine that you would when i
started it i
it was ten thousand dollars ahead but i
and i was hiring like um
young people who didn't pay much but i
imagine you'd wanna you'd wanna bake in
fifteen thousand dollars ahead right
easily
engineers yeah so maybe more so but
let's just say fifteen thousand so
fifteen thousand times
twelve is let's say fifteen thousand
times twelve
is um so that's a hundred and eighty
grand ahead oh i think it's even more
than that it's probably it's it's
so that number you're talking about is
basically seven years ago and
non-engineers
and now you fast forward seven years
double it and then
engineers basically double it again and
so you know what what was maybe
let's say 10 grand is actually you
should be buck you should be budgeting
almost 30 grand 30 grand per per head is
probably closer to reality now
30 grand you think okay so 30 grand
engineers yeah
so 30 grand times 12 is 360. so
360 thousand dollars a an employee
so 360 times uh 15 if you have 15
employees that's gonna be around five
million
dollars and by the way so that's not um
that's not to adjust their salary so
let's say their salary is 200
to something k then you have to pay all
the like you know kind of additional
overhead on salaries which is about 20
that's your fica that's your social
security all that good stuff you have
your rent
you have your free catered lunches you
have your your snacks in the office you
have
all the other [__] that you gotta do
if you're gonna hire in this like
extremely competitive hiring environment
signing bonuses recruiter fees it all
rolls up uh so if that number sounds
high
uh if that number sounds high you'd be
surprised if that number sounds low
you're probably right
and so let's just say like three to five
million dollars is a huge range to have
a team of 15 engineer heavy uh highly
competitive startup
uh to get going it's a lot of money
i talked to this guy the other day and
he had 15 people and i was and he told
me he was spending a million dollars a
year and i was like wait what he goes
yeah so here's how it works in canada
we have these things called the research
and development credits and basically
what that means is
if you're an engineer they're called
them shred credits even though
it's s-r-e-d but i think they just when
people talk about it they call them
shred
yeah i i heard people mention it but i
didn't actually look at the mechanics of
it and i'm not an expert
on it but he was reading it to me and i
was amazed and basically what happens is
he pays their full salary so he pays
some engineer 150 grand a year
and at the end of the year i think he
literally gets like deposited money back
50 of the cost that he's allocated or
he's paid them
he gets that money back at the end of
the year so 160
000 salary is actually only 80k to him
and also in order to manage cash flow
there's these loans
there's loans that you can so he has to
pay the 160
000 so 160 000 bi-weekly so he pays that
out so you have to have cash up front
but he was able to get a loan against
that and so he gets
a loan up front and then at the end of
the year after paying taxes and things
like that he gets
the salary money back this was amazing
and he was telling me all about it and
this guy was based in toronto and i've
never been to toronto but it's
it sounds like an amazing place there's
a company that you should check out for
this
uh that's kind of cool so so most
companies aren't going to make the
drastic move to go move to canada
so there's a company it's part of atomic
if you've ever seen it and while you're
talking pulling that up
i think um i think the best arbitrage
to do this in or one of the easiest is
service-based businesses
so okay so but i think you can't do it
unless they're engineering
i feel like it's only engineering roles
it's
i believe it's for anything that's
uh research and development right which
usually i think is uh no no no because
the at the hustle we got a uh we got a
tax credit for some type of research and
development stuff and i had to go
through each employee
and like kind of guesstimate what
percentage of the time is on like
research and development and and you can
do this for agencies
um you can get a fair bit of money back
so agencies that do a certain type of
thing
and i was at my friend's office uh who
has a new york agency and their office
was like
lavish because and and they spent they i
think they sent half a million dollars
uh decorating it and uh i was i was like
well why'd you guys do it he's like well
this is just what you got to do to like
keep up with everyone and i was like
well [__] i don't want to play this game
i'd rather
keep up with other people in other
places and i think that we have a friend
who has an agency and he sells silicon
valley and new york companies
but he does this arbitrage thing and he
makes way more profit than most
huge agencies the um the company i was
talking about was terminal terminal
dot io i think they basically their
their their startup is a smart idea
they basically were like hey we will
spin up a canadian engineering office
for you
so you want these credits you want these
cheaper engineers but you don't want to
relocate yourself
and your whole business and figure out
shred credits and figure out where to go
find engineers and figure out you know
the best coffee shop in toronto cool we
will do the engineering office for you
and you just pay our bill and like
basically they're kind of like a
recruiting
spin-up agency for for talent in in this
region which i think is pretty smart a
smart arbitrage
now they're doing it in kind of a fancy
way i think anybody could really do this
i think it's a smart idea
yeah and uh so anyway this guy like made
this it like
i had this whole conversation and then
he like kind of he like made this
off-hated comment and i'm like
wait wait wait wait wait what and that
like it totally was like
there was a big shift there um and i was
like i'm sorry i know we're not supposed
to like this isn't like the main point
of this conversation
but can you tell me everything about
this right and that was pretty that was
pretty amazing
you wanna do one more yeah let's do one
quick one um
all right what's fun uh did you see that
reese witherspoon sold her production
company for 900 million dollars
yeah and a lot of people cause to fuss
about that and i don't entirely
understand the business but i don't
think i think people cause the fuss
because they don't understand what the
buyers were getting but what they're
getting
why is this worth 900 million dollars
they get three tv shows and her
her team well so this is like kind of
bro science so i want to preface like i
haven't done like entirely a bunch of
research on this but
reece witherspoon has had this
production company i think since like
the early-ish 2000s so for a long time
what that means is i believe that she
owns the rights you know do you realize
that reese witherspoon is like
like she's gross like over a billion
dollars i mean she's like one of those
people
that she's like the killers like the
killers is a band that like
maybe not everyone says that they're
it's their favorite brand but like
everyone knows
like mr brightside and they like you
know they
they're quietly in the background just
always the best in the most popular but
even though they're no one's favorite
that's kind of what reese witherspoon is
it's like everyone that at least kind of
likes her and
will go to her movies and so with uh
with the deal i believe what they're
buying is like
a lot of ip from years and years of
production work
so uh okay so so i'm looking up i'm
looking up right now
so it says that she started hello
sunshine the company that got bought in
2016.
before that she had another one it's
called pacific standard in 2012 and
that's a subsidiary of it so she kind of
rolled that in
so 2012 so that's only a decade and uh
i guess in 2000 she had another
production company called type a films
and they made i don't know some oscar
gone girl they made you know not nothing
too big
big little lies was their hit recently
and then they had the morning show
which is on apple tv but uh
this is wild this is like so she has a
book club
and the book club has over 500 000
followers on instagram
that's pretty amazing um she also owns a
dude good for her she's a filmmaking lab
that teaches 20 year old 20 girls that
are 13 to 18 the art of filmmaking like
this is
great dude be like she also has a she
also has a clothing brand i think it's
called draper james and they have brick
and mortar stores all over the country
what about what a powerhouse reese is
kind of like an oprah thing where she's
just got
kind of got a web of like a variety of
different things she's uh
she's a baller she's also a kind of a
baller because a few years ago
her husband her and her husband were at
a party and they drove home and her
husband was got pulled over and i think
he got a dui
and she got out of the car and like uh
confronted the cop
and and she's like i'm going with him so
and she got arrested with her husband so
she she's kind of um she's kind of a
boss no
it's amazing i think if i remember
correctly i believe her company was
bought by
kevin mayer who recently was the ceo of
tic toc america but got fired because of
all the stuff and before that
was he's a ceo he was a ceo of disney or
he wasn't the ceo
but he was president and he he like was
the president i think of disney plus
uh before like when they launched or
whatever yeah so he's a big swinging
dick and he
yeah and he basically they bought this
company
to build a conglomerate of like some
type of
media company i don't entirely
understand the structure these deals to
me always seem
very complicated and they seem very like
deal makey
the numbers right because like i'm
looking at the so i'm looking at the
assets so they have
gone girl which which made 360 million
uh
gross in the box office and then the
next highest one was 50 billion so they
have four films
uh of which you know nothing nothing
huge
um and then they have on tv they got big
little lies the morning show
little fires everywhere those are the
three shows you know and then there's
six
that have been bought or sold to either
apple tv plus amazon
abc netflix whoever i just don't get how
you get to that number because
i feel like to do that you you basically
need to
uh like like the office was getting 100
million dollars a year of like streaming
royalties that's like you know the top
of friends you know those are getting
100 million a year
i feel like there's a pretty deep
drop-off after that so i think this is
like
this is like a beats by dre acquisition
is kind of what i see it as which is
basically somebody being like cool
we get rhys we get recent and then some
stuff great
i think that's basically like when apple
bought beats and they're like great we
get
you know we get dr dre and we get
whatever his name is jimmy iveen or
or whatever um plus we get some
headphones all right three billion yeah
we'll
we'll pay three billion for but i think
it's like the most expensive
the company that bought it was
blackstone they're the funding and they
i
i would imagine they don't they're
pretty savvy i don't know if they
overpay for a lot of stuff
blackstone is funding that guy kevin
mayer
kevin mayer's company is the one who
bought this so i think it's more like
kevin
i think it's more like a quibby thing
where kevin mayer
in this case uh quibby was started by
what's the name jeffrey
capps katzenberg katzenberg you know the
dreamwork the guy who started dreamworks
so he was able to go raise two billion
dollars because he's like i'm jeffrey
katzenberg i started dreamworks
and then he used it to go buy a bunch of
content and it all
evaporated into zero dollars um i think
that's
that's you know more like what this is
like versus some
some like real asset that you can
analyze and say yeah it's worth that
um dude congratulations congratulations
to reese for getting that bag
we i would i that she is actually
amazing reese witherspoon's pretty
amazing
have you seen have you seen what she you
know she's like i think she's in her
mid-50s isn't she
i don't know but she's killing it and uh
she's exactly the same
well she looks exactly the same they get
like you know
shot up all over their face and you know
they look the same or
or or it goes the other way and they
just look super weird and they're like
yeah it's just gone wrong
um you know we'll end on this one one
last thing
you know the new coven strain uh is
called like whatever delta
the delta variance delta plus is the new
one
um i was thinking about this this
morning first
delta how shitty for delta airlines just
for for the new covets train to get
named after you
god that's a that's a tough that's a
tough loss to just wake up to it's like
yo which scientist just decided to name
this delta like that's not cool
and then i was like it's a scary name
it's a scary name
i was thinking what would that be worth
to them if you were delta delta's
if you were delta what would you pay
some lobbyist
some some bribery to some scientist how
much money would you shove in the
briefcase
for this to not be called the delta
variant it's like yo
we call this the united variant call
this the
the the southwest variant don't call
this the delta variant
so i'm staying at this hotel it's called
the i don't know what's called gaylord
opryland or i don't know what it's
called
but i i think it's called gaylord i mean
gaylord opryland that wasn't like a joke
that's what it's called
and i'm in this like wing of the hotel
called the delta wing
and it i it it has like a bright red
sign that says delta wing
and i'm just like what i'm seeing is i'm
like oh man this is just like not good
but yeah i don't did you associate delta
airlines with the variant i didn't i
didn't i didn't
it's gonna happen i mean corona like
corona beer with the coronavirus like
you know that can't have been good for
them um
i didn't associate corona beer too much
with that did you
i mean yeah people did it's like that it
became the word of the year
and it's associated with like the
deadliest virus in a hundred years
is the coronavirus and who owns corona
you know nothing good comes from that
except for you know the like college bro
who's like bro i've had i've had the
coronavirus for
you know five years been loving corona
you know but ever since
it's like that joke that's the only
upside you get uh everything else is
downside and so
i don't know i feel like delta should
pay you know
they're worth i think like 25 30 billion
or something like that
how do you pay i though you can't you
can't pay anybody but i'm saying
what would they pay if they could push a
button and make this go away
i feel like this is worth a billion
dollars to delta like easily this is
worth 125th of their
of their market cap this is worth a four
percent swing and like brand value
perception
you know who's going to want to fly on
delta with the delta variant going
around uh i i just feel like that's a
there's some weird association here on
delta
that's my understanding of the delta
wing so i think you're and i'm selling
you're just helping health and delta all
right uh yeah anyways i i feel like
if i could if i could secretly present
the ceo with a button that said pay a
billion dollars and
this goes away this doesn't this isn't
called delta i think he pushes that
button
yeah i would agree um all right i think
that i think we had an action-packed
episode we'll see what people think
um i think we gave like eight good
things
good all right and uh our early morning
episode in the books
enjoy the podcast conference uh all
right i'll see you see ya
i feel like i can rule the world i know
i could be
what
travel never looking back